matt harvey from the other side of town
from all those years ago and you can see
this year it'll be his fifth start
only three walks good control the
strikeouts a little below average as far
as strikeouts go these days and two home
runs
given up in the pitcher scouting report
the long road back he's one of the best
pitchers in baseball from 2012 to 2015
but a 5.78 era cents injuries obviously
serious ones tommy john 2013 thoracic
outlet syndrome yankees have a
one-out-based runner scoreless game
top of the first for aaron judge
he swings and it's a high bounder to
third broncos got it tosses the second
one ureyas to first
count it for two harvey gets the five
four three double play and sees the
minimum
in the top of the first after a half
it's new york nothing and the o's coming
to bed welcome back davey from last year
you could see when he
made his major league debut he ended up
with six starts
actually pretty good only six walks
against 33 strikeouts the last couple of
starts
shot his era up but he broke in with a
bang and
really did himself well last year and
the orioles coming to bat
against davey garcia the 21 year old
right-hander
making his season debut mullins cranks
it to deep right field
judge looking back this one is flag
court bound
and out of here cedric mullins
launches his second home run of the
season
never a doubt as two pitches into the
game
the bottom of the first inning the
orioles have a one-nothing lead
well they sent debbie garcia down to
work on a slider how about your fastball
in the middle of the plate
that ball gets belted that is the 27th
ball that he's hit with an exit velocity
at what over 95 that was 105
in a hurry severino down at first one
nothing o's bottom two here comes
freddie galvez
there's his swing and a rip out to deep
left center field
this one is headed back and it gets off
the wall
frazier able to play the carom severino
waved around third
throw coming to the plate severino
slides in safely
galvest with an rbi double in the
orioles take a two nothing lead in the
second
and the orioles have a run in each of
the first two
against garcia so it's just a high fly
ball probably hard to track you can see
hicks trying to catch it
frazier doesn't really get to it sounds
like he doesn't see it
plays it well and then you can see the
double cut off in no
possible way is severina running all the
way well in between innings the orioles
went out to take the field however
freddie galvez immediately called for
the trainer brandon hyde joined them
freddie galvez has walked off of the
field and into the clubhouse
we head to the top of the fourth at
oriole park at camden yards
the 2-0 to aaron judge and this one's in
the air to right center field fairly
deep tracking his
still going back still going back he
lunges for it and he puts it away for
the out
cedric mullins kept tracking the ball as
it kept
carrying towards the right center field
wall
and at the last moment he had a lunge
for it and he makes the play
no runs one hit two walks four
strikeouts
for matt harvey in his fifth orioles
start and this one's in the ground left
side franco has it
he goes to first base and it's a one two
three inning
for matt harvey and harvey pitcher shut
out so far
yankees have only managed one hit that
was a nurseless single in the second
here's the o2
swing and a miss matt harvey has
retired the last 11 he's faced last time
harvey pitched
into the sixth inning was his final
start with the angels two years ago july
18
2019 against houston there's stanton
at second with his double and here is
the tying run
aaron jones
down the left-field line yankees get a
run
judge gets an rbi and a double yankee's
on
after the double play from the mayhew a
little two out magic
first two pitches this sequence from
harvey were really good this one not so
much
not where he's trying to throw it that's
right didn't finish it
severino off of first orioles trying to
get the run back they lost in the top
half of the unit
he's a left-handed batter and that's a
buck
o'day just blocked and the orioles are
going to add a run
and the orioles lead grows to 3-1 on a
buck
by darren o'day
if you have a block by darren o'day with
men at the corners on your baseball
bingo card
it is your lucky night he flinched
he was on the first base out of the
rubber he flinched and no argument by
darren o'day
as hayes comes down to score severino
moves up to second base
and the orioles get a 3-1 lead now
well matt harvey really deserved this he
went six innings
one run three hits five strikeouts three
walks and hey he deserves a hearty
handshake he pitched great
cedric mullins leads off the bottom of
the seventh against the veteran southpaw
justin wilson and this one's hitting the
air to center field it's deep back goes
hicks still going back
looking up mullins has done it again
cedric mullins is some kind of hot
[Applause]
and another one that wasn't cheap to
dead
center field and was hit well over 400
feet and it's a four to one baltimore
league
we said it before cedric mullins when he
gets home runs against the yankees
the bases are loaded with one out all on
walks
and the yankees will take it here is
rugi odor
swing and a miss he got him on a slider
so there's the second out as tanner
scott just took down
rogue that odor and a high wire act for
cesar valdez
who comes into the game with the bases
loaded and the orioles lead in the
yankees
4-1 that one is lined in a basement
down the left-field line hayes fields
two-run score judges going for third the
throw is in time
final out of the inning is judge was
going to third and hayes makes the throw
well now aaron boone has just been
thrown out of this game hang on a second
aaron boone is in the face of will
little well did he say the run didn't
scored why would he be out arguing so
only one run scored
and the reason why aaron boone got
ejected was because
he waited too long to ask for a review
gary sanchez stepping to the plate
has gone all for three in the game
here's the swing a pulled ground ball to
third should do it franco's got it
tosses to first he got him the ball game
is over
and the orioles take the first to this
four-game
series against the new york yankees by a
final score
of 4-2